marinades are an easy way to add flavor
to any chicken dinner today we're gonna
show you the basics of how to marinate
chicken there are four core elements to
any good marinade fat acid sugar and
seasoning the first element to a great
marinade is fat we're gonna use olive
oil but there's so many different
options that you can use fat is
important because it helps the meat
retain moisture while cooking and it
holds onto any seasoning that you're
gonna add to the marinade the next
element we're gonna need is acid you
could use lime juice vinegar we're gonna
use the lemon juice for this marinade
acid is essential because it helps cut
through the fat it also helps brighten
the dish up now we're gonna add
something sweet you could use brown
sugar maple syrup agave granulated sugar
for this recipe we're gonna use honey
sugar is really important because it
helps caramelization as you're cooking
that's what's gonna get that meat that
really beautiful brown color so the last
thing we need to do is add seasoning
this is maybe the most important part of
the marinade this is where you can get
really creative and make this dish your
own seasoning helps build the layers of
flavor we're gonna do a pretty simple
seasoning for this one with salt pepper
and minced garlic but again you can
really use your imagination here we just
made a simple garlic lemon pepper
marinade but once you have those four
options you can make so many different
kinds like a coconut curry honey mustard
soy glaze and fajita now that your
marinade is ready it's time to add the
chicken you can use any cut we're gonna
use chicken breasts it's really
important to make sure that you're fully
coating every single part of the chicken
once you coat it cover it and put it in
the fridge for 30 minutes - up to four
hours after four hours it's really not
gonna get any more flavor so save
yourself some time when you finally go
to cook your chicken whether it's on the
grill the oven stovetop it's gonna
really have such an incredible flavor
and it's gonna have that beautiful brown
color so now that you know the four core
elements fat acids sweetness and
seasoning you can really get creative
and make some incredibly delicious easy
weeknight dinners
[Music]